voir le monde dans un grain de sable
ou encore tenir l'infini dans le creux
de sa main
2 vers d'un poète anglais william blake
écrit à deux siècles qui nous dit un
petit peu qui est un résumé de ce qu'on
pourrait dire sur les grains le grain
unique contient le monde
c'est finalement il ya énormément
d'espèces de grain tout le monde minéral
nous présente des grains sap et des
cailloux ça peut être des grains de
sable de 100 microns ça peut être des
poussières
ça peut être des graines celle qui
transporte la vie dans le monde végétal
et ça c'est vraiment cette immense
diversité de formes de nature de
couleurs de tout ce que vous voulez et
puis là fini dans le creux de la main
c'est évidemment cette omniprésence des
grains ces grains qui couvre 80% de la
surface de la terre tu couvres
évidemment nos planètes voisines
on va retrouver dans les anneaux de
jupiter en fait finalement cette matière
en grains est énorme et universel elle
est effectivement après l'air si on veut
après l'eau l'espèce la plus commune sur
terre elle est banale les rigoureusement
banale elle est inspirant telle est
inspirante pour faire ce qu'on appelle
de la matière en grains construire avec
des grains ça pète construire une maison
ça peut être faire une pâte à tarte des
grains des graines est simple ça dont
peut-être matière en grains dont j'ai
envie de vous parler en commençant par
nos chers un grain alors que peut-on
dire eh bien première chose c'est
qu'effectivement les grains c'est une
espèce en danger sa pas l'air comme ça
80% de la terre réalisé qu effectivement
le moindre matériaux la même
construction humaine que vous faites ça
ce chiffe entonnant dizaine en centaines
de tonnes que le les grains qui sont
transportés par exemple du désert pour
faire des constructions représentent
parents une estimation
14 milliards de tonnes ou c'est que les
plages sont en train de s'appauvrir que
les lits de rivières on drague aussi
s'appauvrissent donc nous avons une
perte réelle de grains c'est un danger
qui a l'air tout à fait banale mais qui
est tout à fait réelle et on vous dirait
bon c'est pas grave
les grains pendant très longtemps on
utilisait concasseur pour dans des
carrières pour faire tomber des vins et
c'est vrai on peut toujours faire ça on
peut même remplacer les verts pilée pour
le cas c'est comme ces de la silice pour
en faire du sable néanmoins ça marche
pas ce c'est extraordinairement plutôt
de casser des grains le pauvre
cantonniers sur la route de louviers
il dépensait beaucoup d'énergie pour
simplement ouvrir ces grains mais crée
de la chaleur l'encore un petit petit
statistiques vous rien à retenir mais
c'est des gros ordre de grandeur 30 % de
l'énergie consommée sur terre sert à
casser de la matière autant que le
transport on n'en parle pas parce que
c'est pas noble fait pas des
améliorations qu'on améliore une
automobile
mais on s'est très mal passé les choses
effectivement cette énergie elle et elle
est perdue parce que cette matière va
prêtre recomposées ou ne la récupère pas
après coup et donc cette histoire est
une histoire dangereuse grave et il faut
faire attention dans notre consommation
de matières et docks les constructions
que nous pouvons faire avec ces gars
alors cette sens des grains elle est
connue depuis longtemps dans le grand
siècle classique qui plaisait à
jacqueline de romilly
il y avait démocrite démocrite va
introduire la notion d'atomes ce qu'on
ne coupe pas ses petits grains ultime
qui a semblé vont vous aider à
construire des solides des litiges c'est
ça bouge un peu ou dégâts si c'est
totalement dispersé donc la notion de
que cette matière en grains nous aide à
comprendre la matière
dans lequel nous vivons la matière le
monde matériel ça continue et c'était
coulon qui était un ingénieur qui
étaient des ponts qui construisaient les
problèmes de talus ça a été la bo é té
au monde la révolution attaquerez la
cristallographie et puis ça continue et
j'avais pratiquement dans tous les
domaines de la technologie de la science
et des applications
on a utilisé des liens donc elles des
sciences des grains j'ai parlé du génie
civil construire une route
je vous dirai pas le nombre de tonnes
mais c'est considérable la non de
matière qui est utilisée creuser un
tunnel aussi le nom à la matière qu'il
faut casser au domaine le génie civil le
gilet procès d' excuse moi le génie des
procédés qui est une science très
développé dans cette région si dans
lequel la matière très divisés comme le
plus fier de charbon va être amené à
brûler plus efficacement et donc il faut
réduire en grains en poudre tout ce
qu'ils possédaient relais sciences de la
terre en particulier la pédologie la
science des sols dans lequel les grains
cohabite avec de l'eau de l'air avec des
racines du végétal avec du minéral bien
sûr avec eux tous ces petits animaux qui
vivent dedans donc 7
c'était cet ensemble de grains qui
constitue le sol puis le sous-sol les
sciences de l'environnement tout le
monde en parle et à juste titre on
prendre un glissement de terrain
comprend d'une avalanche comprend d'un
éboulis comprendre la formation d'une
dune
ce sont des sujets qui ont intéressé
aussi une communauté lâche mais je
voulais dit s'agissait de science des
grains au pluriel ya 30 ans avec un ami
très cher pierre gilles de gennes qui
j'ai pu travailler 50 ans de ma vie
nous sommes demandé si on pouvait pas
faire au lieu de descendre et grains une
science des grains et par quoi démarrer
parce qu'elle plus simple un sac de
billes
pas de la haute technologie comme on met
des billes ensemble comme on fait une
pyramide de bi comment on fait couler
des débits à partir de dinde simplement
de s'habiller d'un sac comme on les fait
vibrer en laye donc on a créé en france
toute une école sur cette science des
grains et pour ça nous sommes appuyés
sur le fait que paradoxalement on savait
beaucoup mieux comment les atomes se
déplaçait dans un solide que de savoir
que quand on dégrade les places et donc
ont utilisé ce qui nous faisait tout ce
qu'on appelle l'atomisme le tout petit
pour essayer de comprendre plus gros et
on a construit cette science à ce moment
là j'avais écrit un livre qui s'est
appelée du sac de biotalent sable
c'était vraiment le sac de billes le
modèle du prince william il savait rien
mais il va venir et donc pendant ses 30
ans nous avons donc développé cette
science est elle est devenu
internationalement très développé vous
d'avoir une revue comme nietzsche heures
très sérieuse vous trouviez sur la
couverture pourquoi est ce qu'à un
château sable je vais en reparler
tiens quand on le met de l'eau pas
troupe pas trop peu donc est alors ne
nous sommes avisés
je me suis avisé de décrire ce livre qui
est sorti à 15 jours jeudi jacob g
associer deux deux jeunes amis jean-yves
de l'aisne et farouk rajaï qui eux mêmes
sont en charge cette année du congrès
mondial
pas de regret pour les grains qui se
tient à montpellier au mois de juillet
de façon à voir l'actualité du travail
qui était fait là-dessus non ce ce livre
là je pense nous décrit un petit peu les
différentes situations dans lequel
existent des grains dans lequel on
travaille avec des grains dans lequel
ils servent à énormément de domaines de
la science et je pense qu'effectivement
nouvelle points mais ce point sera
déplacée évidemment parce que ce à quoi
nous sommes arrivés c'est une ingénierie
des grains c'est plus uniquement la
bille c'est vraiment des grains qui sont
des formes qui s'attache d'une certaine
façon qui permette des constructions
différentes n'est pas si ça arrivera à
être utilisés par l'informatique jean
dutrey pas du tout plat ce petit petite
structure on puisse aider à faire des
structures macroscopique donc qu'ils
vont avoir des prix
et particulière à c'est ce qu'on appelle
réf volontiers ces maisons échelle pas
le microscopique par la grande
construction mais c est chez
l'intermédiaire de matière alors il faut
bien sûr que je vous parle de choses un
peu concrètes de cette matière j'aurais
pu vous décrire des exemples dans tous
les domaines d'application vous montrer
comment finalement en orbite de rentrée
on utilise les céramiques poreuse pour
pouvoir et empêcher que des raids pour
permettre le refroidissement j'aurais pu
vous montrer au contraire commande est
plutôt en céramique finalement n'utilise
à l'opposé des grains extrêmement dense
etc
j'aurais pu prendre tous les autres de
même que vous voulez alors j'ai choisi
en prendre un seul le domaine de la
construction
alors ce domaine de la construction est
un domaine qui nous est cher et vous
allez voir que il est intervenant il
éteint il intervient dans des problèmes
d'hier mais aussi les problèmes de
demain alors la première vue vous montre
effectivement la fascination nous
pouvons tous avoir tour où est il
comme nous pouvons tous avoir pour ces
grains le château de sable
le château nos enfants ce qu'est ce que
c'est qu'un château de sable ça n'est
rien d'autre que des grains de sable qui
ont été collées entre eux par des
petites beau feydeau qu'on appelle dépôt
capillaire la capillarité
c'est ce qui fait que vos cheveux ce que
l'on semble donc vous quand vous passez
avec de l'apec avec de l'eau c'est mais
cette capillarité elle fonctionne bien
s'il ya de l'eau mais si on n'a pas trop
là on s'est posé des questions
savante commandant le volume d'achats
taux de sable ces grains tienne
qu'est ce qu'il faut pour qu'ils
tiennent plus longtemps et qu est-ce qu
on peut rajouter pour ça donc on va y
rajouter de l'argile
donc ceci nous sert de premier modèle le
premier modèle de notre enfance mais il
illustre assez bien ce que je veux dire
le deuxième évidemment la nature ne nous
a pas attendu
vous avez ici un modèle d'une termitière
comme on rappelé on les rencontre d' en
afrique centrale
celles ci elles peuvent faire quelque
chose comme 6 humaines de hausser
termitière les termites les ont réalisés
en mélangeant leur bave leur salive les
grains de terre les grains de sable et
le soleil ayant desséché ferrand des
véritables soudure consolidera ses
grains et elles vont faire des salles
elles vont faire des couloirs
elles vont faire une aération
ventilation ces pays sont humides et
eschau et ceci c'est un peu un modèle de
construction ne sais pas si l'humanité a
utilisé ses modèles dans l'afrique
orientale mais en tout cas là ces
constructions servi ici cette ville
d'étaples et souvent la manhattan du
désert et j ban au yémen chibane vous
avez des immeubles qu'il faut 30 mètres
dos vite étages construits avant la
période préislamique donc ce n'est pas
d'hier et qui continue à exister quête
au patrimoine mondial de l'humanité
mais ça n'est qu'à des très très très
nombreux exemples de la cabane jusqu'à
des maisons très évolué jusqu'à des
mosquées de l'utilisation de cette
matière en particulier en afrique
mais est ce que cette construction font
véritablement partie du passé la réponse
est non
elles font partie d'aujourd'hui vous
avez deux milliards d'habitants sur
terre qui vivent dans un habitat en
grains en matière ici ce que je vous
montre ses seins lauréats
monsieur fusil charme d'un prix
s'appelle tera watt est donnée aux
meilleurs architectes de construction
modèle il s'agit d'un village en chine
détruits en 2008 par un tremblement de
terre les les paysans chinois route et
formé à faire de l'habitat en terre
auront construit localement leur habitat
et ceci étant c'est fabuleusement
important pourquoi parce que ils
n'utilisent pas du ciment le ciment est
une est un producteur de gaz carbonique
fabuleux
passer du carbone notation monsieur diop
vous envoie du co2 il n'y a pas le choix
si vous utilisez des matières onu une
construction dite vernaculaire
qu'utilisent les ressources locales
eh bien vous fait évidemment toute cette
économie de transport cette économie de
l'utilisation du ciment
donc je crois qu'il ya véritablement
pour l'avenir de tout à fait modeste
l'utilisation de cette construction en
terre et écologiquement
extraordinairement importante
vous retrouverez dans tera watt d'autres
exemples effectivement de construction
de toutes sortes qui effectivement tu
sais on est passé de nos modèles
initiaux du sac de billes à des modèles
plus évolués de façon à éviter
effectivement ces structures se dégrade
par l'effet de l'humidité et c'est mon
dernier chouchou et j'ai eu la chance de
travailler là dedans
ce sont les bétons à hautes performances
on dit beaucoup de mal des béto mais ces
bétons ont pu être améliorées
créée à rome autant du panthéon premiers
siècles de notre ère redécouvert en
france dans le 19ème siècle des grands
projets grands progrès vont se faire
dans le xxème siècle est là depuis
quelques années depuis quelques
décennies on a découvert ces bétons à
hautes performances et travaillant dans
ces projets j'ai pu comprendre nous
avons pu comprendre comment on pouvait
améliorer ces matériaux en rajoutant à
des gros grain des petits des petits
jusqu'à des fines jusqu'à les tout
petits grains hombourg le matériau tant
qu'on peut jusqu'à ce qui est très peu
de vide
ce faisant on renforce considérablement
le matériau si en plus de ça on y ajoute
des fibres ça devient béton très porteur
allons à gagner plus là encore une fois
on économise plus on a quelque chose de
dur - utilisent ciment moins aux
produits de co2 mais en même temps on
produit des structures plus légères
ça c'est la résille que vous pouvez voir
en de l'intérieur du mucem de ce musée
moderne de marseille
est ce que vous deviner derrière c'est
une passerelle qui monte à la forteresse
un genre l'autre côté du vieux port et
cette passerelle à 4 cm d'épaisseur dont
vous êtes dessus c'est comme si vous
étiez sur un métal élastique
donc nous avons réalisé de la légèreté
nous avons réalisé de l'élégance dans un
matériau qui évidemment n'est au départ
n'est pas très appétissant
voilà un petit peu les exemples que j'ai
voulu développer en montrant comment
notre recherche pour faire cette
ingénierie des grains avait rejoint une
tradition extrêmement importante
alors je voulais pour terminer vous dire
que bien que scientifique ayant dirigé
une école qui se préoccupaient de
littéraires sciences humaines et
sociales
eh bien nous avons trouvé énormément
d'applications dans les sciences
sociales les sciences humaines de cette
matière au gain imaginez qu ici il ya un
petit feu qui se déclenche
suffisamment pour déclencher pour
effectivement faire que les gens partent
par la seule issue de secours
qu'est ce qui va se passer exactement
comme si vous êtes vous essayez de faire
poulets dans un entonnoir du riz basmati
du real ils bloquent n'y passe pas les
gens passent pas il faut beaucoup plus
de temps en cas de panique pour évacuer
des mondes que si vous avez si vous êtes
comme sade dans une sortie normale et on
a fait des modèles qui soit un modèle
granulaire on s'est intéressés les
problèmes d'encombrement
on s'est intéressé à deux problèmes
d'embouteillages on s'est adressé un
blâme de parking et puis en plus de sens
et intéresse au fait que les grains
finalement chagrin individuel c'est un
individu dont on les met ensemble
socialise ils font des groupes
comment passe-t-on de l'individu au
groupe comment se sont organisés ces
échanges de toute façon voilà donc c'est
un petit peu ce que je voulais dire
juste un dernier petit mot parce que
j'ai eu la chance de diriger le pas et
la découverte c'est que j'ai pu vraiment
entraîner des jeunes qui découvraient
qu'il découvrait comme l école l'état
solide l'état liquide l'état gazeux
un matériau qui était des fois solides
défaut liquide des x games eu des fois
tout autre chose
des fois pas te et que j'ai pu entraîner
ces jeunes leur faire admirer leur faire
aimer les promener sur le sable j'espère
que ça une petite promenade sur le sable
avec moi qui ne nous aura pas trop des
plus bon après midi
[Applaudissements]